welcome back to new rock stars i'm
whitney van laningham and doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness has
revealed a new mystery sorcerer
character named sarah according to the
latest funko pop releases obviously
she'll look amazing next to the porg
funko on my bookshelf but i've got a few
questions about her identity to explore
with y'all who exactly is sarah in the
multiverse of madness i've got a few
theories about who she might play based
on what we've seen of her character's
outfit plus details i picked up from the
super bowl trailer this video is brought
to you by squarespace they're the
all-in-one platform to build a really
cool website and run your business the
latest funko drop includes a bunch of
strange variants like defender strange
blue strange supreme strange hovering
strange and spell circle strange america
chavez rindra the minotaur sorcerer
christine palmer scarlet witch mordo
wong and sarah one go-to assumption is
that sarah could be sarah wolfe from the
comics wong's star crossed love interest
but they couldn't end up together
because he already has a lifelong
betrothed it's worth noting another
known sarah in these comics sarah
crowler mordo mother to baron carl mordo
whether this sarah is supposed to be a
version of wong's squeeze or murdo's
mommy it's clear the movie is going in a
different direction from both this sarah
is outfitted in blue robes and a gold
belt and wears her hair short similar to
the other warrior sorcerers in the
trailer and while her garments aren't an
exact match to wongs mordos or any of
strange's they are clearly sorcerer
robes she looks like she may have been
part of the same lineup as defender
strange rintra and this alternate wong
i'm going to call defender wong who may
or may not be the same sorcerer who does
a barrel roll while lassoing gargantos
of all these funko releases notice how
only these sorcerers appear without
capes and clearly did the homework from
the edna mode fashion school knock it i
think their matching attire suggests
that they all come from a team-up of
defender sorcerers a cleanup crew of
badasses deployed whenever another dope
breaks the multiverse and unleashes the
nastiest interdimensional beasts much
like a squad of multiversal ghostbusters
these are the folks you call to in
doctor strange's words scooby doo this
[ __ ] upon re-watching the trailer i was
floored to discover on the body of
gargantos a series of glowing markings
at first i thought they were part of his
anatomy but these are actually
externally applied tattoos or brands of
some kind these same markings can
actually be seen on the anatomy of the
ribbony monster that attacks america
chavez when defender strange saves her
we also know that gargantos attack began
with him chasing america chavez through
the city streets so that makes two
fantastical inter-dimensional monsters
both with the same glowing markings
covering their bodies both targeting
america's chavez and both subdued by a
league of sorcerers who wear the same
specific kind of robes there is totally
a connection here so the question now is
what did america chavez do to piss off
all these creatures if 2022 is the year
you finally start your own business
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence for
that business the kind of website that
looks great works great and gets you
paid squarespace has a bunch of great
features to help your business to be
successful you can present members only
gated content create email campaigns or
add online bookings for appointments or
sessions all from the squarespace
interface they've also got great
analytics to help you figure out what's
working and what's not like if all your
traffic is coming from minnesota maybe
you should consider moving to the land
of 10 000 lakes is that crazy i don't
know check the analytics the squarespace
video studio even helps you make pro
level video content head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.comrockstars to save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or
domain that's squarespace.com new
rockstars for 10 off your first purchase
of a website or domain america chavez
kicks star portals through realities and
she comes from the utopian parallel a
dimension that ends up destroyed perhaps
a few of the star-shaped doors she
kicked down created a wake of
destruction through the wrong realities
like rue on euphoria ferris buellering
through one too many quinceaneras and
that made america chavez multiversal
enemy number one to countless ruined
realities with a massive target on her
back in the eyes or eye of gargantos and
whatever type of eye holes mr ribbon
sees out of but these hunters are also
being hunted the glowing markings
covering their bodies i believe could be
the scarlet letters labeling those
beings as an invasive species like white
blood cells latching onto a toxic
presence in the body or the yellow
barrels that quint latches onto the
shark the markings slow them down and
mark them for detection making them
easier to track and hunt so as our
doctor strange struggles to prove
himself and find his place in a growing
multiverse sarah defender strange and
their friends represent the team doctor
strange would have aligned with if he
wasn't so stubborn if he didn't make his
first impression with the leader of the
avengers by calling him a douchebag and
slapping him with his gay all of the
variants our doctor strange meets with
embody one of his flaws and this group
will show his struggle to play well with
others so coming back to sarah being on
this team if she is an alternate version
of sarah wolf wong's never girlfriend or
sarah crowler mordo she could also
represent an overlooked truth for ar
wong or armorto or marvel could really
lean into disney plus new parental
controls for mature content combine the
two sarahs and have wang bang mordo's
mom unlikely to appear in this movie i
like to believe in my heart that there's
a branched reality where mordo grows
disillusioned with sorcery because wong
becomes a step dad in our mcu based
reality all three of these sorcerers
strange wong and mordo are bachelors who
committed their lives to the mystic arts
just three single dudes and an ancient
one strange is the only one whose social
life we know anything about but
christine palmer seems to be the one he
let get away by the looks of the trailer
footage of strange's longing gays on
christine's wedding day that theme is
coming back in the multiverse of madness
but this film is also pairing strange
with an alternate reality christine
palmer one from a reality where she and
her strange became more of a power
couple who both have careers at
multiverse hq multiverse of madness
could do the same thing with huang and
mordo present them with alternate
reality versions of the women in their
lives if they had made different choices
and allowing them to see these women as
more than just a stock money penny type
or an absent mother but as a fierce
sorcerer with the same defensive
abilities that they have follow me on
instagram and twitter at whitney puppy
follow new rockstars subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
sorcerers
[Music]
you